the US mission stands right over the
road from the United Nations the
prominent location reflecting the fact
that the u.s. is both a founding member
and host country but in the foyer of the
building the space reserved to the photo
of the sitting ambassador is empty this
despite the fact that Kelly crafts
nomination was confirmed by the Senate
a month ago the United States must
continue the drumbeat every forum at the
UN the US presence at the UN has
essentially been degraded since the
departure of nikki Haley at the end of
last year she'd been a powerful advocate
of US interests in the organization the
seat on president Trump's National
Security Council adding weight to her
influence she became the
administration's point person on the
issue of North Korea in particular the
President and Kim have had a summit and
was fierce in joining her president in
calling us rivals to account
we need China to do more president Trump
called Chinese President Xi this morning
and told him that we have come to the
point that China must cut off the oil
from North Korea that would be a pivotal
step in the world's effort to stop this
international pariah in Hailey's absence
the u.s. role in the Security Council
has sharply diminished senior members of
the administration such as John Bolton
really want to sideline the UN and
simply not having a full-scale
ambassador here in New York has been a
very good way to minimize the UN's
importance and Russia and China have
been quick to pull the vacuum left by
the u.s. ramping up efforts to set their
agendas and the Security Council and
further afield Russia deeply evolved in
Syrian negotiations proposing a Gulf
security plan China managing to raise
the contentious issue of Kashmir in the
Security Council for the first time in
50 years unlike her previous Esser
Washington's new ambassador will not
have a seat in the Trump cabinet yet
another indication that this
administration no longer sees the UN as
a viable body to advance its agenda
apparently unconcerned that ceding at
once all powerful influence in the world
buddy to its most bitter rivals Mike
Hanna al-jazeera United Nations